yeah you always recount the story about
how you um won this quite significant
acting I did I got to perform in the
Kennedy Center on uh in Washington DC
and so awesome there was
a this is actually kind of awkward as
well but I'll tell it so there was well
no no it's a cool story but like there
was a there was a contest called the
Irene Kennedy Casey Kennedy C Kennedy
Center American acting theater Festival
what what age is this around this is all
college okay it's the entire United
States and I would argue it's probably
the most prestigious competition that
you can do in college and no one from
our school both my community college and
my college had ever won it we never we
gotten runner up a couple of times and
up for a whole country for the region so
there's five different regions and we
represented the kind of the Midwest
region which included Wisconsin Chicago
Illinois
ohioes you are the representative for
the Midwest is what I'm he was that like
a competition was that like a
competition as well to get to that
points so yes so I'm not explaining this
this is like an anime tournament yeah
this is like a sports this like a Sports
Anime we got to win regionals ma we can
do it let me let me so let me scale it
back so if you're in a show a college
show you'll have an adjudicator come
watch it and the director chooses one
actor and the adjudicator chooses one
actor to then go on to this Regional
festival and I was selected for five
years in a row cuz I'm wow took me and I
lost every single time the first four
years what you what did you have to do
so you go there and you have to do a
two-minute scene with a partner um
that's it can be self-written it can be
from a famous play it could be whatever
it could be a musical it could be
Shakespeare whatever you want it's
actually three minutes the first round
is three minutes if you make it to
semi-finals they take like eight five or
600 different pairs and then they narrow
it down to 32 or 64 and then you do
another two-minute piece so you do a
3-minute and a two-minute and then if
you make it to the finals you add a one
minute mod monologue right so on my
fifth year I was like okay this is
getting embarrassing I've been nominated
a lot oh you never got to the finals I
made it to semis once I see and and at
the school at that time a lot of people
looked up to me as an actor because I
took it really seriously I may not have
been the most naturally gifted but I
would really put put the work so I think
a lot of people really had high
expectations right so I decided that for
the final year I got this amazing
partner named Callie and she's such a
great actress but she was really young
she was like 19 or 20 and I was like 23
at the time right and so you're asking
someone really new to theater to take
some big risks as we do these scenes so
the first scene was really easy It's the
funniest piece of literature I've ever
performed in and it was written by my
old acting coach so it's this guy meets
this girl and story is old as time but
the whole point is for the first minute
and a half 2 minutes their inner
monologue is talking instead of them
directly so he's saying oh my God it's
her and then she says it's him and It
All Leads up to their initial awkward
conversation easy clear made it to sim
we knew we were going to make it to sim
this scene was perfect right the problem
was it was so funny that we didn't have
a contrasting piece strong enough so I
talked to this old wizened like Jedi
acting coach and I was like I just don't
trust this second piece that we have and
she goes I have just this scene for you
but you have 20 20 hours to get it into
shape and I was like all right and she's
like it just came out so I know the
playright personally I'll email him and
ask him if we can get permission to use
his works and I was like okay this was a
really interesting play called red light
winner and it's extremely graphic and
the problem with this scene was the
character I played starts with him with
a girl downstage looking up at at him
saying I love you and he says you've
never loved me or something like this
yeah yeah and they have this brief
tussle of intense emotional connection
of making
out this is in front of an audience and
then he takes her behind a table not so
different than this lifts up her shirt
and U spits in his hand and drops his
any he
well okay dogs yeah and then yes that's
actually kind of key um then while while
this is happening right this thing his
phone goes off and he covers her mouth
and he takes the call and it's from his
wife saying that he'll be home later and
then the real acting the tough part is
is the girl has to take this information
this betrayal and visualize it for
everybody to see plus all the risque
stuff we're doing yeah he hangs up the
phone finishes whatever that task was
looks at her as he's belt you know and
he says I told you I didn't love you and
that's the end of the scene big contrast
huge contrast Whiplash for the the
audience but but a great way to show R
he was down bad
down was down you have to be red up this
bricked up down bad all these terms come
full circle and uh the the the key part
of that scene actually is she does have
HIV and now he in turn will get it so
that's not displayed in that particular
scene yeah so then we did we made it to
finals so now it's down to the final 16
people in our region and this is like
we're in Uncharted Territory can we be
one of the two winners to ever make it
out of this region and go to Washington
well for our school yeah the entire
Midwest and so cuz two people go from
each region and uh it was like okay this
is it and we drew numbers on which order
we got to go in and I drew 15 out of 16
which I loved I was like you get to
watch I don't watch anything but I want
to be near the end because I know that
those scenes that we do are so powerful
it leaves an impact very much and the
monologue so we go to the we start the
thing and I actually was so confident
that I slept for about 40 minutes during
the first round so I was just like calm
down rest and my partner poor Cali was
just sweating sweating and terrified so
I'll never forget it though man we we
went out there and it was in Kansas
actually the regional that year was in
KU so it's my own backyard I had a
chance to defend home turf we walk out
there and there's 2,000 people in the
auditorium and they're all they've heard
rumors of some of the I heard about this
scene so it gets dead silent and that's
already extremely exciting so you're
like everyone's anticipat oh man it was
so you could feel the place just ready
to go so I was terrified you know but
you got to own it so I said hello my
name is Peter this is my partner cot
we'll be doing three pieces for you
today and inside I'm just I'm all
bricked
[Music]
up you're
emotionally then in the finals you to
perform three scenes we have to do the
the com it's a six minute and it's
ruthlessly timed if you go over time
somebody will put their hand up at 15
seconds and then they'll stand up and
say finish and if you go over time
you're disqualified oh [__] so this is
where thank you for it's like you're
helping me tell this story well I'm
trying to visualize just so I can get my
the head that be awkward if they shall
finish like the second scene I presume
that's to make sure obviously if you
were to
finish obviously obviously timing is a
huge part of acting and and being on
Queue and on time is I'm guessing that's
why right there was one problem though
we didn't realize was the the comedic
scene was so funny with 2,000 people we
had to pause for laughter so that did so
I think they actually give you a
10-second Grace per period so like you
know whatever they whatever but so like
we do the first scene it kills people
are going crazy with laughter people
there's already like tons of cheering
and then we got to put that behind us
and we had to do that really serious
scene yo my god dude when that whip dude
you could not hear anything during that
scene dead silent one guy in the back
was like you know and it was just it was
dead and then I had like friends and
family watch and they didn't know I was
going to do this scene where I'm like
yeah and it's just but it's fine because
it's it's theater so and then we did a
monologue and I know that Cali went off
stage and I had to do a it was a really
great place uh play called um recent
tragic events about 911 and uh it was a
great monologue it wait you did a KN
it's a good play though it's a it's a
really powerful play about American
thing I've ever it was really it was
still relatively topical back it's like
within 10 years of this well you said
2003 right this no this was this was was
five years of me doing it this must have
been 2008 or n or something like yeah
still so and that play I played the
neighbor of someone as we we're at an
apartment we're watching the the events
unfold and her sister happens to be in
the tower was she okay and it's just
like a two-hour look into that moment of
time yeah but this character was really
funny very quirky it towed the line
between serious and comedic right and I
and I remember I was kind of kneeling
down telling this this end of this story
and I saw the person stand up and I was
like we're out of time but I still took
that one extra second I'll never forget
it my entire life I stood up and I got
to see the entire audience and it looked
like some weird watercoloring because it
was just all these images and faces and
when I got to say before I could finish
the words thank you the place went
ballistic just insane
clapping theater programs being it was
like some sort of ridiculous thing yeah
and whether I knew if I won or lost it
was irrelevant I felt so satisfied after
all these years of training that we had
a moment that meant something to someone
else which is the whole point of theater
and so it was pretty exciting and then
when we found out they uh we ended up
winning first place on that competition
we got to go to the Kennedy Center we
got to perform on the stage and I got a
nice cash prize for best comedic scene
of a um that was the one that we'd
written
and that money went straight to me
coming to Japan oh hell yeah did you end
up winning in uh we did not get the
first place tragically this is actually
point of
contention this is really amarrass it is
pretty I mean I don't hold them
accountable but it's really embarrassing
that this happened yeah during our
second scene where the phone goes off we
had rigged it already so that someone
would call the stage manager for the
Kennedy Center who's not actually doing
anything they were just watching yeah
their phone went off during our scene
like like a and so I think I reached for
the phone before the moment and like and
it it cie kind of rushed well she didn't
do anything wrong but like she moved on
to what I was doing and then we kind of
like corrected it and then it was like
wait that wasn't and then my phone went
off when it was supposed to and you're
like and as a stage manager you're kind
of like you really should had on you're
the last guy on Earth you really should
not have that on but you're [__] up
yep so um other than that you know I
took those things that I learned and I
taught drama in high schools here i'
I've been in some various funny
different comedic things for Japanese
media working for NHK similar to you BBC
so it's always been a through line of
like my my life and my career was doing
theater all from those radio bastards
who told me I was was the origin story
often often a should experience is a
bigger motivator than a good one I find
y so there you go for sure your life is
an anime it's crazy we're just going
through all like the cannon events in
your life I do have one the we one brief
one that sucked really bad when I told
you failure it's a quick one I there was
ESPN is a pretty big Sports Network you
told me this story so sh dumb and I was
like it was right after I'd been fired
from the radio station and I told I was
they came to our town to to interview
anybody who it was the first like
reality TV show during like Survivor
season 1 was still on you know and it
was dream job where you could win a a
job as a host for sports center for a
year and I was like dude that's so sick
and my my acting coach like yeah go and
[__] do it what are they going to do
z95.7 you and I was like yeah you're
right I can go and do it so I wore like
my nicest suit and I I always looked
kind of wild anyway with my messy hair
and like I always stuck out in a way so
we're we're in line there's like 300
people and they have this camera crew
coming along and they they stopped at me
and they said hey you look pretty
interesting What's your deal and I was
like oh I'm a I'm a theater student at
the University and they're like oh whoa
we got any theater you can show us and I
was like never say no never say no don't
be afraid of failure and I was like yeah
I do but it's not it's a it's a really
uh well it's a um it's a serious piece
like go ahead and show it it was like
really serious it was like my dad like
abused me and now I'm
like and so this is a sport center I was
like but I I I did the monologue as best
as I could and I remember uh I remember
one of the lines in the the the
monologue is is what the hell do you
think you're doing is one of the lines
yeah and I remember it was a camera like
that with like this enormous camera and
I could as I'm doing the monologue I see
like the cameraman look like should we
just cut this guy what's going and I you
know worst M I was like what the hell do
you think you're doing and I and they
were like dead silent not the eruption
that we got years later and uh they they
were like thank you so much for your
your monologue that was really good good
luck inside I was like thank you and
then the guy next to me I was like that
did not feel good he was like was not
good better you than me and I was like
okay and then I I was like I didn't get
invited to Bristol Connecticut I did not
get invited to be a part of sports
center so I felt like okay at least I
can live with the fact that I tried I
turn on the the first episode and
they're like welcome to ESPN you know
dream job thousands applied and it shows
all these people who are being and they
said let's take a look at the people who
didn't make the cut and I was like
please don't do please don't do this and
it has like all these different people
and then one person does like a shitty
job and then right after it it zooms in
on my fat face going what the hell do
you think you're doing and then I was
and then I got like 10 phone calls I oh
you want Sports and I was like oh my God
so somewhere out there in some dark dank
closet there's a there's a tape of me a
full video of that horrible monolog get
media lost media thank God but yeah
that's that's when you take willing to
fail too far at least when you were us
you didn't do
though said was was like
where can I use you for like one second
and then my dad abused me while
auditioning for Sports Center was not
the play I
imagine I could I should have just
improvised anything other than
that was a risky move you know let's see
if it turns out you live and learn so
but these stories in the moment they
felt [__] horrible but when you look
back on him now a great story learning
learning experience and also great
accept your the aspects of one's life I
think stories about absolutely it's
completely all right yep holy [__] some
wins and some losses I yeah I I worked
at McDonald's a long time that was just
one big loss I didn't even get B job oh
that's right you applied and you got
turned down by McDonald's and my dad
thought I was going to be unemployed for
the rest of my life and here you are and
he was always kind of right yeah he's
kind of especially right same nailed it
nailed it